saab a donc il connaît bien le brigadier
impliqué dans la sphère michel on en a
vu tous les images un bien sûr de ce qui
s'est passé
regardez c'était dans le xviie quatre
policiers se mettent à le tabasser
violemment regarder le 19 ils sont
directs assez violent des moissons dans
la la j'ai peur je me demande ce qui se
passe je comprends pas ce qui se passe
créé à l'aide
qu'est-ce qui se passe franchement ça va
tellement vite je me demande même si
c'est des vrais policiers
à ce moment-là il ferme la porte il me
tabasse voilà où tabac soit pendant cinq
minutes et 12 secondes en effet les
policiers du 17ème arrondissement après
une vingtaine de coups de poing et une
dizaine de penser pas leur niveau
mondial alors ça va on a tous vu cette
vidéo
tout le monde a réagi dessus le
président de la république le ministre
de l'intérieur là la plupart des
ministres les journalistes vous vous
connaissez bien donc ce brigadier
impliqué dans la pierre michel est pour
vous cette vidéo ne reflète pas la
réalité pour vous c'est un homme bien
tout à fait donc j'ai travaillé avec ce
brigadier en question on a travaillé
quelques années ensemble nous n'étions
pas dans la même brigade mais on avait
des des commentaires des interventions
en commun il a toujours été clean
il était bien noté était très bien notée
il était posé calme professionnels donc
effectivement aujourd'hui quand on voit
ces images je ne reconnais pas alors
vous pour vous donc vous vous dites
qu'il ya quelque chose vous pouvez pas
là pour moi il ya eu un dérapage
effectivement il ya eu un dérapage
les vidéos sont choquantes on est tous
d'accord et aucun problème sur ça vous
avez essayé de le joindre et non non
j'ai eu des idées des nouvelles de de ce
brigadier par deux personnes d'accord
ils vous disent quoi alors lui lui
discute avec personne n'a pour l'instant
d'accord dakar series sûr et aussi il
est sanctionné
déjà sanctionné des apps condamné
administrativement donc prédire
selon vous est ce qui pouvait avoir des
penchants vous avez travaillé que
pendant cinq ans c'est ce qui a été dit
voilà ce qu'il pouvait avoir des pochons
violent parce que quand on voit les
vidéos il ya des hantises d'avoir
dépensé au violon peut-être voilà
racistes alors pas du tout raciste
d'accord je vais m'entendais très bien
avec lui en dehors du travail on a déjà
vu des coups ensemble avec les collègues
et c'est quelqu'un de très bien de
douves et à l'esprit de faim de
sympathiques quoi rien deux pas du tout
violent d'accord aujourd'hui il est
condamné il est déjà condamné
administrativement pour vous il n'a pas
pu péter les plombs non il n'a pas pété
les plombs
il a dérapé et eu un dérapage il ya
dérapage si on est d'accord
les vidéos sont choquantes on est
unanime il n'y a aucun souci mais par
contre elle est où la différence entre
le dérapage de ses finances était bien
s'il ya une différence d'après vous non
pour moi cette vidéo elle est choquante
on est on est d'accord il n'ya aucun
souci sur sa jeune va pas revenir dessus
aucun problème il ya eu un dérapage de
ce fonctionnaire il n'est pas du tout
comme ça il n'est pas du tout violent de
base oui mais aujourd'hui quand on porte
une en a pas on n'a pas l'intégralité de
la vidéo quand on a une matraque
comporte une arme qu'on est con et
représentants des états représentant de
la loi représentant la paix est ce qu'on
a le droit aujourd'hui de faire ce qui
se passe là à la retourne à des
problèmes quand on a des problèmes
familiaux quand on a des problèmes on
est sous payé on fait trop d'heures et
to stop stop
ma crainte c'est un truc dans ma ville
elle n'allait pas je dis stop j'arrêtais
parce que ça vous évitera pète un plomb
mais quand vous pète un plomb et vous
tuer des gens moi je peux pas accepter
ça
moi aujourd'hui je peux pas accepter
qu'on dise c'est pas un dérapage il a
pété les plombs
c'est pas vrai c'est des gens ils ont
des 357 magnum ou des 11 43 la ceinture
et vous allez venir
le gall il est bourré de problèmes on
les sent au relais soit allé dans la
nature on mangera du tous pourris
problème le collègue a alors derrière
l'uniforme est un humain